all right so despair Davion and Mike
again you know hey what's up kid Peele
we heard back yet you know the show is
still good man y'all still doing your
thing dying a lot so you man you still
making mistakes dog still making
mistakes for real man like in this
week's show man y'all had that scene
call flicker and whatnot you know the
scene man like you know in the first
part here in the kitchen and you flicked
then the second part into getting the
toilet he'd get flicked then he out at
the graveside and the grave come up and
flick him in nose right and that was all
good man y'all made one mistake dawg
y'all should have made them fingers
dicks man stop on the Facebook day why
would you turn the fingers index given
like any in the kitchen like I'm gonna
dig in the toilet and then that makes a
lot of sense
and then when you add clothes what's
down there
just muhfucka knows what it did in
anyway that's chicken wings later on
you're seriously keel come on man why
are you higher I'll sit is clearly party
niggas seriously man we know when the
show we don't stop taking our
stairs
you